from the
nsf
qlci center and the dairy
qsa center
so
let's start with
torrents
we'll talk about
quantum simulation
chemistry yeah all right let's get
started
all right so yeah my name is torrence
tatina um i'm a new postdoc here in the
quantum pod
um
so
if this will work
this happens
okay yeah so yeah i got my phd in
quantum chemistry at the university of
washington um in june um and just got
here
and yeah so i think be good to start off
first what quantum chemistry is because
i feel like some people might not be
familiar
um so like the really basic picture of
course is that we have molecules that
are made up of electrons and nuclei
electrons are small and they behave
quantum mechanically we can describe
them with the wave function
ideally if we want to
compute the wave function of all the
electrons in some system then we can
compute properties that are of interest
to us
things like reaction energies light
matter interactions the dynamics of
molecules and materials anything that
we'd want to develop new materials
molecules
so the ultimate goal is of course to use
simulations to accurately design you
know new medicines photovoltaics new
sensors from the desired properties on
the outset
um so that's the ultimate goal that we
like to be able to do
um right so again if we can use the
coulombic interaction to build up a
hamiltonian between the electrons and
nuclei
and optimize for some mean field get a
set of orbitals for some system this is
typically what's done in just standard
quantum chemistry calculations
but in order to build up the exact
weight function we then use the
electrons in all these orbitals that we
got
we need all basically all uh
configurations of electrons in these
orbitals and this ends up being an
exponentially scaling problem
which of course is intractable um
so like for example even just a tiny
molecule methanol
um
has upwards of 10 to the 17
configurations of electrons and
even just a medium or small size base is
set
so that's intractable with just six
atoms
all right so in general what do quantum
chemists do is create new polynomial
scaling approximations to the exact wave
function of interest
that can be tractively solved with the
goal of still capturing all the accuracy
of the exact wave function
in being able to predict uh new
properties of some arbitrary system
so
in comes hamiltonian simulation if we
had access to a quantum computer we'd a
be able to provide an exponential speed
up in that simulation typically what
people look at is computing the exact
ground state energies uh sometimes
energy differences and this is just a
super basic overview but we have some
second quantized picture of the
medi-body system typically this is in
the form of
one body and two body operators and we
can sort of compile that down to some k
local hamiltonian on a number of poly
operators and then with that create
a unitary form of the propagator
to evolve it in time so we prep some
approximate
guess to the exact wave function evolve
it in time and then measure some
property let's say usually the energy
so
with that
um we can make the problem even more
complicated so one issue that comes up
in quantum chemistry is that
a lot of materials of interest actually
contain um heavy element atoms
and these aren't just these aren't
actually accurately described by just
the coulombic hamiltonian
so as you can see here
if we have uh just this is just the
uranium atom
um on the left hand column these are the
orbitals you get out from the regular um
uh coulombic hamiltonian and if you
introduced special relativity and the
fact that the speed of light is finite
um
then you get two major effects one of
them being called
typically referred to as scalar
relativistic effects
which actually provided a contraction or
expansion of core orbitals and then also
uh degenerate splittings called
spin-orbit couplings so you can see with
these heavy elements
additional
effects added into the hamiltonian
actually
comprised of a completely qualitatively
different picture
so
the takeaway here
is that
the non-relativistic chemistry
hamiltonian itself is an approximation
um so what we need to do is to use the
dirac equation instead of the
schrodinger equation to
accurately model systems that have heavy
element containing atoms
and so as you can see
um in this example here this is a
theoretical calculation done
basically the takeaway is that for some
property of interest in this case it's
the ionization potential
in order to get quantitative accuracy
with experiment we actually have to have
both a very close description
so this is basically a um
a method that cl is very expensive and
closely approximates the exact wave
function
but also includes relativistic effects
up to the qed level so
um
basically the takeaway here
is that since non-relativistic
hamiltonians are approximate that
actually puts a fundamental limit on the
accuracy of quantum chemistry regardless
of whether you're using a classical or
quantum computer
so one research question we had
is can we efficiently simulate a
relativistic uh chemical hamiltonian at
the level of effective qed on a quantum
computer
and sort of the very short answer is uh
yes you can and it's efficiently
simulatable in polynomial time with uh
polynomial gay complexity
essentially the difference in this
hamiltonian is
that you have
non-particle number conserving terms and
you only care about conserving charge so
essentially you add in not only a field
of electrons but a field of positrons as
well and you have to
appropriately deal with that but your
hamiltonian's still in a form
where you can get this efficient
calculation on a quantum computer
typically what we looked at in this
specific numerical numerical case that
we studied
studied was uh for a second order
chocolate trotter suzuki decomposition
uh using quantum phase estimation
um
yeah so just super quick overview and
yeah this this paper is still in
pre-print form i just put the link in
the top right corner uh but we actually
uh obviously did a lot more than just
this but yeah check it out
with that um some future work
um is for that model we just looked at a
really simple electric relativistic
electron gas
and what we want to do is look at more
realistic basis sets and also more
realistic models that represent the
problems we're interested in
um
one other thing that would be
interesting
is also looking at uh first quantized
representation instead of just second
quantized
um but yeah in general some interests
are of course relativistic effects in
many body systems
also
algorithms for including the quantum
description of nuclear motion
and vibrations and molecules which are
really important for uh design of new
materials and um also some
hybrid quantum classical algorithms
and um also property prediction beyond
just ground state energies
and uh with that i'd like to just put my
acknowledgment slide of course thank you
simon's institute
umesh and brigitte as well for having me
here and my collaborators and my
previous advisor so with that thank you
very much
and so while we are changing over to
fermi if there's a good question
so would you say that there's there's um
there's much more to do to go beyond
this basic model that you use oh yeah
there's there's a lot more to do because
this is very simple and in fact in this
case
um while we derive bounds that included
um nuclei um essentially just any
nuclear center the numerical calculation
we did could only include just basically
just the relativistic electron gas which
means no nuclear centers so obviously we
need to do more on the numerical side
but at least this gives us an idea of
how we can simulate uh relativistic eqed
type hamiltonians in the future
okay so next speaker is
talk about post